welcome to xxx you wanted me back you
could have just asked me well on the
action-packed Canadian set of xxx return
of xander cage we couldn't help but
notice all the incredibly strong females
kickin serious five every character is
so unique and so different and every
person brings a spin to their role and
and there are very strong women the
typical is so badass boobies is so
baller now that's a team I can work with
here we go
Nina's been incredible and she plays she
proves that you can be both um hot sexy
and smart
my character is I guess the cue of our
franchise she's like the nerdy tech girl
who invents all the gadgets that Vince
character Kage uses when he's out on the
field and she's the brains of the
operation I guess you actually know what
you're doing down there
yeah that's what she said mm-hm Wow I
see these roles with strong women and
you know as you know that's becoming
more and more common these days that was
the things that wasn't really around
before you know and now we're getting to
see it which is exciting and being able
to learn martial arts or go back to the
boxing that I used to do or learn gun
training stunts it's been awesome
although nina dobrev and Ruby Rose are
both well-known Hollywood actresses the
latest xxx installment will introduce
North American audiences to Indian
Superstock deepika padukone what does it
mean for you to be part of this film and
be
what to make this with Vin Diesel it
means a lot you know I think i think his
actors you're constantly exploring and
hoping to be exciting work you know and
to me I look at this the same way that I
would do a film back home
of course it's a much bigger platform so
which are you
I'm xxx and even though the face of the
franchise Vin Diesel has a very tough
exterior he admits that part of the
reason he wanted to reprise his role of
xander cage is the way makes him feel
it's insanity insanity it's one of those
characters that I knew needed to return
and for me there's something therapeutic
about playing a character that I'm
always laughing and always always
enjoying myself and you can see it and
everything that I do